reg good morning how are you seed or do
we have breaking news music on this show
yes we do to it with the recent events
of what I heard of Ray Allen retiring I
just want to let everyone know I am
coming back to try and reclaim my
three-point crown I'm only 450 behind
and I said I know the amount off the top
of my head but I am coming back now that
I know who has retired but by the time
you got to Ray Steph Curry will have
passed you probably reg oh my god I
didn't ok we just went around the I'm
here to report that I am now going to
stay retired and not enter the
Association i just bought a Cavs jersey
with your name oh no that's Mike Miller
that was mike miller nevermind all right
wait we we just went around the room and
we wanted to know if you would
acknowledge that any what anybody was a
better shooter than you and NBA history
now you know I can't answer that very
much the same way ray Larry Bird Craig
Hodges dale ellis Steph Curry klay
Thompson the late great Drazen Petrovic
if he could speak we can't we can't
answer that it's shooting is so
subjective and as much time that we've
all put in the lab all of us we all are
going to say we're the best shooters
walking we are wired that way so I
cannot answer that question ray cannot
answer that question Larry Joe cannot
answer that question because I know what
all of them are going to say what if I
took you out of it
who would I handicap who do I think yeah
personally greatest shoot on on this
show I've always said that I thought
drazen petrovic Petro vich was the best
shooter I've ever seen that I've ever
played against watching Steph recently
over the last few years I'm starting to
question that and I'm going to say this
about Ray now that he's retired and we
know he's never coming back knock on
wood but he may other than Michael
Jordan he was the only other shooting
guard that I spent extra time in film
sessions out of all the people because
you know how much I love watching tape
on people and preparing before games
Michael Jordan you had to spend extra
time you had to try to find one little
wrinkle something that you could use
during the game to help you out Ray was
the only other shooting guard where I
had to spend extra time in film sessions
because it was almost like looking in a
mirror when I was watching him so it was
very difficult to game plan for him
because not only was he a great shooter
but he was fantastic and pick and roll
situations so another tie no he's not
coming back ray I love you I have to
give him props because he's the only
only shooting guard that I had to hit I
had to game plan so much for and you
know what people forget that ray used to
be able to dunk on people or people off
the dress and you go back to Milwaukee
or even Seattle I mean ray was really an
athletic to guard and now people just
remember him as that guy running off
pics and shooting threes and he was so
much more than just that well and
obviously the big you know the big shots
with you know Miami and the big three in
the championship in miami and boston but
if you go back as you mentioned to
seattle and milwaukee and we got locked
in a playoff series with mock milwaukee
when it was Sam Cassell big dog and Ray
and we had our hands full with those who
cry those three guys and in particular
ray because he was so crafty with moving
without the basketball and what George
Karl did which was beautiful a lot of
times they would put big dog and Ray and
pick and roll situations and I mean this
is before small ball before it was
so prevalent in today's game and it was
just a nightmare to guard against he's
Reggie Miller the formal introduction
Hall of Famer Turner Sports NBA analyst
and one of the great players shooters of
all time he's got celtics cavs coming up
thursday at eight Eastern on TNT we also
talked about the 1996 draft and if I
said you could have one teammate from 96
and a two-on-two tournament so you can
have Iverson kobayashi you can have
Steve Nash who else at Ray Allen anybody
else in there Paulie that's it that's a
big full okay so if you could take one
of those two and then I'm going to have
my own to 12 team who would you take is
your other guy oh man i would go with
kobe i see em you two would get along
with i would go with Kobe I almost
leaned towards AI i almost leaned
towards a I but you're gonna have to
guard someone at the other end and I
know Covey's a two-way player I would go
with Kobe what if I said he was your
teammate for ten years I'm going with
Steve Nash we all want Steve Nash as our
team eight years yeah and I mentioned
that Iverson is probably culturally the
most impactful player in its behind
Jordan in NBA history with with what he
did with with tattoos and the cornrows
and how he dressed his style he didn't
conform to anything or anybody look
there they had to reinstitute a dress
code because of AI because everyone was
going towards what you know the saggy
pants and tattoos and the cornrows and
not that that it was bad but um you're
right and let's not forget his size you
know I mean very generous six footer but
the biggest heart probably of any seven
footer I ever played again so that 96
draft is special my question to you is
this with Ray and now
seeing his retirement will he be a part
of that 2021 hall of fame class with kg
Tim Duncan and Kobe well am I correct on
that then because if if so that will be
arguably not arguably in my opinion that
will probably be the greatest hall of
fame class to ever be inducted I know I
know that Jordan it was Jordan David
Robinson and John Stockton was one that
was pretty good yeah but this 2021 if
ray is a part of that even if ray isn't
a part of it those three is fantastic
but if Ray is a part of it that's
arguably the greatest hall of fame class
going in in 2021 the dance will tell you
I've been fascinated with this story and
because it's Metta World Peace it makes
it even more interesting he said that he
was inappropriately touched by a ghost
in a hotel in Oklahoma City do you know
the hotel that meta tis talking about
I've you stayed there it's called the
skirvin yeah but it's affectionately
known i called it spooky manor and uh
enough said Metta World Peace said it
right yeah have you been inappropriately
touched by a ghost in that hotel Reggie
Miller I have never been go on
inappropriately touched a spooky manor I
will say this there there are odd things
that do happen with lights flickering
and things moving places like you'll
play something down and you turn around
you know 10 15 minutes later and it's
slightly moved but that could be your
imagination playing tricks on you but
isn't there the scary hotel Milwaukee as
well I yes we stayed there as well um
what's the name of the Pfister the fist
right yeah the Pfister yeah I stay down
yeah but isn't that all part of your
imagination look we just finished
Halloween and people want to hear ghost
stories and coming from Metta World
Peace okay all right who's scared Metta
World Peace or that hotel
well which which Ron Artest my water jet
in Indiana hell of a lot earlier than
that hotel you had to walk into the
locker room sometimes and you had to
think what what the hell am i doing like
what it what is going on who are these
people in here with the patient yeah but
ron was one of my he was one of the most
favorite guys that I've ever played with
because you never knew what you were
going to get on the court he played one
hundred and ten percent off the court
sometimes it made you kind of scratch
your head but you talk about a guy you
know they talk about walking in a dark
alley and you know who would you go to
war with who would you want to be in a
foxhole I would want to be in a foxhole
with Ron Artest because the dude plays
hard but at times it other times he made
you kind of scratch your head but it's
hard for me to say a bad thing people
say aren't you upset with Ron Artest he
derailed your last year the whole riot
and everything I was like no because it
not only was it a learning process for
wrong because now he's the world
champion and he understood what it takes
and the sacrifice being on a good team
when he came to the lakers to win so to
me was a learning process for him did it
did it hurt us perhaps I thought we had
what are the top three teams that year
to win a championship but not having him
on the court yet it certainly hurt us
but it was a learning process for him
yeah and look at him now no you know
they're gonna ease him into being a
assistant coach there looks like with
the Lakers good for him yeah he's a lot
of fun I mean there's been a
transformation there with him he's a
great there's a great spirit about him
when when he comes on the program
there's there's like childlike innocence
with him at times Theodore I'm telling
you at the end of the day Ron always has
a great heart he always wanted to do the
right thing but when you're young and
you're butting heads with another young
superstar and Jermaine O'Neal you know
I've said this on the show my greatest
failure as a veteran player was not
being able to get those two guys locked
in a room and on the same page because
at the time we had the best interior
defender and Jim
pain in the best uh frontcourt into a
defender and Ron Artest so we had the
best on both teams but I couldn't get
those guys to understand the team
concept you know they were both young
and they both wanted this is my team I'm
going to take control of it and it kind
of derailed us because we were good we
were young we were edgy um we had
everything you know and we had great
coaching with Carlisle it just it's my
greatest failure let it go keep your
head up burn I gotta let it go yeah but
I mean you you killed me because I was
ready for my you know cueing the music
and i was kidding rated come back to the
email no only for think about this I
needed 413 to catch ray and so I was
figuring that would be like four years
or if you're Steph Curry season come on
man ridiculous you can listen to reg
you'll be on the call for the Celtics
Cavaliers thursday at eight Eastern on
TNT reg great to talk to you to be part
I'm going to be a part of the float the
Indians they're gonna finish it off one
of these games you would assume right
shows your if they win you're gonna be
on the float I'm gonna be the baseball
version of junior Smith as cold as it is
I'm gonna be no no no no no don't do
that no now now yep no don't I can't now
no no no no no no you know what how
about you where jr smith's jersey i
would do that there you go I like bad
boys I would rock a junior it's
absolutely absolutely we'll be looking
for it thank you dread shake travels
feared or Reggie Aloysius Miller Jr the
third the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience